today's video has been made possible by
the great courses plus
an on-demand video learning service that
gives you access to some of the best
courses
lectures and documentaries stick around
until the end to find out more about
today's great offer
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
greek mythology is full of insane
monsters
epic battles courageous heroes and
ruthless gods
which resulted in some pretty gruesome
and awful punishments
being a king in ancient greece in no way
made you exempt from punishment
in fact many of these stories today
involved kings who
overstepped their boundaries and showed
a little too much hubris king ixion is a
prime example
of why you should maybe stay on zeus's
good side
when he married his wife he promised to
give his father-in-law a substantial
gift
that is often known as the bride price
once married ixion went back on his word
and refused to pay
his father-in-law then stole some horses
from ixion to
even the score however ixion wouldn't
allow his father-in-law to have the
final say
and so he plotted his revenge inviting
his father-in-law to a feast
when he arrived ixion pushed his
father-in-law into a pit
of burning coals murdering a guest in
ancient greece was considered one of the
worst crimes one could commit
and so he was exiled by the neighbouring
kings who refused to absolve him of this
crime
he was left to wander alone until he was
driven
insane of all those who could have taken
pity on ixion funnily enough it was zeus
who invited him to a feast with the gods
rather than showing gratitude towards
zeus ixion began to lust for hera
and zeus did what any loving caring
husband would do
he created a cloud in the shape of his
wife and tricked ixion
into impregnating this cloud seeing this
betrayal
zeus struck ixion from the heavens with
a bolt of lightning
hermes was then ordered to bind him to a
burning wheel
that would spin across the heavens for
eternity
another king invited to dine with the
gods was king tantalus
he also disregarded the hospitality zeus
had shown
choosing to steal ambrosia and nexa to
take back to his people
as well as sharing some of the god's
secrets as if this wasn't bad enough
tantalus would continue to test the gods
in order to repay the hospitality shown
to him he would invite the gods to a
feast of his own
he wanted to know if the stories of the
gods were true whether they could hear
and see everything or in this case
whether they could tell
what they were eating was forbidden and
so tantalus killed his own son
and served him to the gods this plan was
largely a failure as
all the gods except one knew something
wasn't quite right about their meal
demeter who was absent-minded still
worrying about the disappearance of her
daughter
paid little attention and ate the boy's
shoulder
when the true contents of the meal were
revealed the gods were furious
first of all zeus ordered the fates to
bring the boy back to life
by boiling the chopped up body parts
they were able to reform him
his missing shoulder was replaced by an
ivory prosthetic
made by hephaestus zeus then turned his
attention to tantalus
who at this point certainly deserved
whatever punishment was coming his way
he was placed in a pool of water above
him
hung the branches of a fruit tree
whenever he reached out to grab a piece
of fruit
the branches would raise ever so
slightly just
out of his reach whenever he bent down
to take a drink of water
it would also recede just out of his
reach
tantalus was given the gift of
immortality but in this case
it was very much a curse for eternity he
would feel
a hunger that could never be satisfied a
thirst that could never be quenched
an ever-present reminder of the dangers
of temptation
eternal hunger is a punishment we see
again with
king eric sixen for his crimes against
nature
erisekton ordered all of the trees in a
grove to be cut down
the issue was this grove was the sacred
grove of the goddess demeter
the king wanted to cut down the very
last tree with his own hands
and in doing so he killed a nymph who in
her last
breath cursed him demeter hearing this
call
summoned limos the spirit and goddess of
starvation
and insatiable hunger she placed herself
in erysikton's stomach and so began
his torment he felt hunger like never
before
every time he ate the hunger only grew
he sold everything he owned it just to
buy
more food and even then it wasn't enough
with no money and no food the king began
to devour himself
by sunrise there was nothing left
secrets being revealed by kings happened
more than you may think
king sisyphus revealed the location of a
nymph who was being hidden from her
father by
zeus as punishment zeus ordered thanatos
to
chain him in tartarus however the king
was able to trick
thanatos by asking him to demonstrate
how his magical chains worked sisyphus
was able to trap thanatos in his own
chains
and escape his punishment with thanatos
in chains
and unable to perform his duties this
meant
nobody on earth could die which to many
may not be an issue
but if you happen to be let's say the
god of war
and you are now stuck in endless battles
where no side could win
you can see how ares may have taken
exception to this
aerys found thanatos and freed him from
his chains
making sure sisyphus completed his
journey to the underworld
once there he was made to push an
enormous boulder up an endless hill
hades enchanted the boulder to roll back
down to the bottom
whenever sisyphus felt like it was
nearing the top
the true punishment was not the physical
strain on his body
sisyphus considered himself an
intelligent man
enough so he felt he could challenge or
outwit
the gods resigning him to an eternity of
this
pointless mundane activity for eternity
only led to frustration and over time it
became
maddening eventually he lost the thing
he valued the most his mind
the last king on today's list is king
minos who definitely suffered one of the
more
peculiar punishments when minos made his
claim to the throne he prayed to
poseidon
to show him a sign that he was the
rightful king
of crete poseidon responded by sending a
white bull
from the ocean to show his gratitude
minos wore to sacrifice the bull in
poseidon's name
however he had grown rather attached to
this bull
and when the time came he sacrificed
another in its place
this angered poseidon the bull he sent
was special
and he was not about to be tricked and
disrespected with the offering of an
ordinary animal
if minos loved this boss so much then so
would his wife
pacify poseidon cursed her with a
burning passion for the bull
it grew so bad that she made the
inventor daedalus
create a wooden cow so she could climb
inside
and mate with the bull if having your
wife fall in love
with a bull wasn't enough of a
punishment she became pregnant and gave
birth to the minotaur
which would terrorize and plague the
island of crete
a rather common theme or punishment in
greek mythology
is transfiguration or metamorphosis
altering or transforming someone into
something else
in this case usually an animal or
something grotesque
an example many will be familiar with is
medusa
but even then this is a rather
contentious topic
if you go by the story that appears in
ovid's metamorphoses which is very much
the roman version then yes
athena transformed medusa into a
snakehead monster
as punishment for defiling her temple in
response to this story you have versions
where
athena transformed medusa into a gorgon
in order to give her the means to
protect herself
there is also the very common belief
that medusa was born a gorgon
overtakes a very similar approach to
athena involving the story of
arachne a talented weaver who is
transformed into a spider
in a competition with athena arachne
creates a tapestry that is perceived as
disrespectful to the gods
in ovid's metamorphoses athena defends
her father's name
beating and shaming arachne until no one
would ever want to buy her tapestries
again
arachne then chooses to take her own
life
and athena transforms her into a spider
a warning or lesson against hubris
in the alternative version it is zeus
himself who takes offense to this
tapestry
and forbids arachne from ever weaving
again
when she takes her life this time athena
transforms her into the very first
spider
so that she may continue creating
beautiful tapestries
in the form of a spiderweb these two
stories are a matter of perspective
you can view them as a punishment or a
gift
neither is wrong the same can be said
for the story of lamia
originally a libyan queen lamia fell in
love with
zeus and this ended poorly when hera
found out about the affair
she tricked lamia into eating her own
children
and drove her insane before eventually
transforming her into a monster who
could never
rest again there is another version of
this story where the transformation is
done
by zeus he does so so she can seek
revenge upon those who exiled her
and took away her crown there are some
other examples of transfiguration and
metamorphosis that are far less
ambiguous
act hayeon was a hunter who stumbled
across artemis while bathing in a spring
when her handmaidens alerted her of the
hunter who stood there staring
she wasn't too happy before he could
explain himself he was silenced by
artemis
who told him he was not to make another
sound
otherwise she would transform him into a
stag
upon hearing the sound of his hunting
dogs he called out to silence them
and in doing so he had cursed himself
axhayon ran through the forest trying to
escape his fate
but it was already too late the
transformation process was almost
complete
the irony of this punishment is that
once he was fully
transformed he was hunted down and torn
to pieces by his hunting dogs who he had
trained for that very purpose
artemus appears again in a similar story
but this time it's a boy called
cypriotes who stumbles across her
bathing in the woods
the boy is given a choice he can either
be transformed
into a girl or he can just die which
admittedly
isn't much of a choice needless to say
cypriotes chose the option that did not
involve
death and so he became one of artemis's
many followers
some other victims of transfiguration
worthy of a mention
include a young man named ahelios who
challenged aphrodite to a beauty contest
and lost resulting in him being
transformed into a shark
there is also killoni a nymph who hermes
transformed into a tortoise
for being too lazy to attend the wedding
of zeus
and hera out of the many punishments
we've discussed today
which do you think was the worst there
are of course many we haven't discussed
and if you think any of those are worthy
of a mention then let me know in the
comment section
as we mentioned at the start of the
video it's sponsors like the great
courses plus that make this content
possible
i'm sure at this point we're all pretty
used to on-demand subscription services
netflix disney plus and so on the great
courses plus is fairly similar
but instead of feeling bad after binging
12 hours of an awful tv show
out of boredom you can be productive and
learn something new
there is a vast catalogue of lectures
courses
and documentaries taught by ivy league
professors and other fascinating
individuals
the topics range from finance fitness
food and travel
to history philosophy science and
literature
so there should be something there to
tickle everyone's fancy
you can stream the great courses plus
from your tv tablet
laptop or phone whichever you prefer
if it's about space or dinosaurs then
i'm normally interested
but the great courses plus does give me
an extra resource when it comes to
researching
video ideas and coming up with new
topics if you enjoy greek mythology
and other ancient religions then i
suggest you try
the pagan world if that sounds good
you can start your free trial today by
visiting thegreatcoursesplus.com
mythology or by simply clicking on the
link in the description
so give it a try and let me know if you
learn anything particularly interesting
as always i've been your host mythology
and fiction explained
[Music]
you